[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing the oldest wizard in history
and it might not be who you think it is
although it isn't touched on much in
this series
we know for a fact that witches and
wizards live longer than us muggles
rowling even revealed in an interview
the dumbledore was 115
the time of his death dumbledore is 115
and professor mcgonagall is a sprightly
70.
wizards have a much longer life
expectancy than muggles
but just because we're told what aged
and would all live to
it still doesn't really give us a proper
point of reference dumbledore didn't
really die
under natural circumstances and while he
looked old
i think that he probably had many more
years left in the tank
with a bit of digging i was able to find
a resource that gives us a little bit
more insight into the ages
of witches and wizards according to the
ministry of divine health
the average wizarding life expectancy
was reported at an average of
137 and three-quarter years old
in the mid-1990s this means they live an
average
of 57 percent longer than humans who cap
outs at
79 not bad but what's the limit
how long can they actually live if
things go well for them
the longest living human or muggle on
record is reported to have been
zhen galmo a super centenarian from the
south of france
she was born in 1875 and actually died
in the same year as dumbledore
1977. this made her 122 years
and 164 days old beating out our
favorite hogwarts professor
by seven years so if wizards live an
average of 57 percent longer than humans
then i think that it would be reasonable
to assume that the oldest living wizard
was probably around 191 or 122
times 1.57 right here's where it gets
tricky
there are many witches and wizards on
record that easily outlived this number
and by a substantial margin the man that
usually comes to the forefront of
people's minds
when they think of a long life is nicola
flamel
aka the philosopher behind the
philosopher's stone
flamel was a french scribe born in the
year 1330
in the city of pontois he lived in paris
for the majority of his life
and spent much time there over the
course of the 14th and 15th century
flamel is cited as having discovered how
to make a philosopher's stone
a magical artifact with the capability
to grant the possessor eternal life
flamel along with his wife bernal were
able to produce an elixir of life
from the stone allowing them to live
ludicrously long lives
in fact they probably would have been
able to live forever
but for mel aware of the dangers of what
could happen if the stone fell into the
wrong hands
destroyed it as they were no longer
using the elixir of life
flamel died when he was just shy of 700
years old
not a bad run interesting that jen
kalman's father
was also called nikola and also held
from france
but even though flamel lived in nearly
700 and used an elixir of life
he still wasn't the longest living
wizard so who was
according to a snippet from the daily
prophet the longest living wizard
was barry winkle barry wee willy winkle
celebrates his 755th birthday in style
tonight
by throwing a huge party for all the
wizards and witches he's ever known
30 million are expected to attend
tonight that was the description under
the headline
oldest wizard is 755 which appeared in
the august 14th
1991 issue of the daily prophet there's
a lot of speculation floating around
regarding
how exactly barry achieved that age the
most popular theory is that barry
possessed some sort of
philosopher's stone or elixir of life of
his own
the second theory is that barry was just
of unusually good health
and reached his absurd age naturally
pushing the limits of what witches and
wizards can achieve
in a magical world where seemingly
anything is possible
i don't want to discount anything
however i really don't think that barry
could have outlived someone like flamel
without some sort of assistance and i am
of the impression that he too possessed
some kind of elixir of life what do you
guys think how did barry reach the ripe
age
of 755 let me know down in the comments
section
below until next time it is the unknown
we fear when we look upon death and
darkness
nothing more